hey guys this is Steven booth and
welcome to this set of my new music
video half gone it's one of my favorite
songs that I've written like ever why
did you want to come here to do it well
I mean there is no snow unfortunately
but in my mind I was like essentially a
god how do I make my version of
essentially the notebook in the notebook
you know this scene works like it's
raining
still over
it seems like that just crush my soul ah
so clearly Steven is a romantic but
where did the idea for half gone come
from I was talking to somebody and I
just said that out loud
and they were just like so that again I
was like I don't know how can I love
someone with my heart I've gone there
just like like why aren't you making
that a thing being so close to your
brother Charlie and have you seen like
his meteoric rise and seeing what he's
gone through
[Music]
cuz he talk to you and give you advice
mean truthfully yeah it's always good to
have a perspective and obviously when
I'm not sure about things like yeah I
always you know I'm gonna go to my
family members regardless but you know
in this case it's so specific that it's
like it's great it's so much fun that I
just get to wake up and say I make music
sometimes it's hard to go to the office
every day and I get that and like for me
it's cool because I could be the
soundtrack to your morning sometimes or
if you're really sad or really happy and
it's like if it's help if the song helps
me get closure or makes me happy or sad
or whatever it does if it's able to
resonate with you like that while you're
going to your office one it like that's
cool to me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]